how has life been for you man since uh
all the [ __ ] has been kind of like
collapsing around us in los angeles
because i know you've been out here
pretty much the whole time
yeah i mean i never thought that it
would be like this you know what i mean
like
especially dropping music and [ __ ]
putting the album out in a pandemic [ __ ]
like this not being able to move around
yeah like touring yeah like even even
like this
you know what i'm saying like at least
it opened up a little bit for us to be
able to do it
something like that hey honestly that's
why
you know we've been talking about me
doing this podcast for so long and like
they shut the radio station down so we
can't have guests there
probably till next year and i'm like yo
this zoom [ __ ]
this instagram live [ __ ] is like kind of
whack yeah
i mean it's not no to me honestly
there's not no feel there
yeah and it's like everybody like you
know what like i mean and
and it's it's good for artists because
you know like
these radio promo runs are draining if
you're
a rapper right and you got to go and
bounce around all these corny ass radio
djs and every [ __ ] market it can be a
lot
now you can just be like all right let's
do a zoom yeah just straight you know
what i mean but for somebody like me i
feel like
putting out my first album after all
this time i feel like i wanna
i would wanna no you wanna go you want
to do that it probably wouldn't
it's crazy to think that this is your
first album yeah super crazy and and i
always tell people this
is 17 projects before that's what i'm
saying like
what makes this the album and what what
about all the mixtapes
i mean like this is your first album
it's so wild to say that out loud like
yeah it throws people off too you know
what i mean because it's like
they put they pull up projects and be
like this wasn't the album
i'm like no i didn't say that it was
like it was a mixtape you know i mean
like
i didn't go i didn't go like pause as
hard as
as like on a mixtape i can go in there
and do that [ __ ] in a day or two
if i really want to you know i mean like
the whole project right
and then put it out in a week but with
the album
i feel like i had the album six times
before
and so this is like the sixth rendition
of your first album yeah and then i just
i've been trashing it the whole time
like god ain't ready it ain't ready
ain't ready
yeah what's like obviously you know
everybody knows you from being taylor
gang and and um
you're kind of like wiz's right-hand man
i think like
you know if if you see whiz you you know
you see chevy like it's
it's you guys are you know we talked
about this on ig live you're like the
scottie to his jordan and like
um what is like
do you feel like there's like a lot of
pressure like being like
this is your first album i know that
like
a lot of people have been waiting for
your [ __ ] for a long time bro and like
it's almost like we haven't i mean
you dropped last year right didn't you
drop a mixtape last year was that 2018.
you know i dropped a
project last year too yeah you're like
it's crazy though like
do you feel any sort of pressure like
being as like
we've been seeing you and and you've
been putting out so much content but
this is like like i feel like that debut
album energy is so different than
everything else that anybody could ever
do because it's like you think of nas
and nomadic and
doggy styling mm-hmm and that's where my
mind was that anyway like
of course it's the baby picture you know
i'm saying so i thought you know in my
mind thinking of like classic
music and how i used to listen to albums
from start to finish without skipping
that was my whole thing like i'm gonna
do the when it's time i'm gonna do the
baby picture because that's like my
classic
albums yes like the the nasty covers
ready to die cover the wheezy cover you
know what i mean so like
all of those were like inspiration to me
having it but i
and and i don't which i'm did little
wayne was the carter three
was a little wayne quarter three i think
so yeah quarter three nah
and the pressure thing is i've been out
the door for me you know i mean like i
ain't gotta i don't gotta live up to
nobody's expectations or nothing like
that
anymore i feel like years ago i probably
had to right because wiz was at
so high of a point that people were
looking like
oh his man what is he going to do next
blah blah blah blah blah but i never
lived in that world you know i mean i
just
basically just did my own [ __ ] and he
supported the same way
right regardless